there's a guy who just won the Pulitzer
Prize and he's a guy who thinks that
he's a chick
and he's won the Pulitzer Prize now uh
for his writing he's a book critic in
New York Magazine
he won the 2023 Pulitzer and he's he's
known as a pro-trans writer so this is
where it gets a little bit
controversial in 2019 this guy his name
is Andrew Chu he now goes by Andrea he
published a book called females in which
he said things that were deeply
misogynistic
I almost never use that word but they
were they truly expressed a contempt and
a hatred for women and you sometimes see
this this line of thought and this
inclination among the transgender
movement not all the time but some of
the time and so here's what he said
in his book females he said getting f'd
makes you female because f'd is what a
female is
he describes himself as a once being
quote a sad pretentious boy Furious
about rape hopelessly addicted to
pornography
he says almost every night for at least
a year before I transitioned I would
wait till my girlfriend had fallen
asleep and slip out of bed for the
bathroom with my phone I was going on
Tumblr to look at something called
porn this is that kind of pornography I
did an interview with the the editor at
Redux and actually the story comes from
Redux uh this is the hypnotism
pornography that plays a large role in
people transiting themselves but no one
really wants to talk about it so this
guy admits it this guy who just won the
Pulitzer Prize he said yeah this kind of
pornography trans to me I looked at
something called porn I discovered
it by accident one night scrolling
lazily down a pornographic rabbit hole
and he goes on he says pornography is
what it feels like when you think you
have an object but really the object has
you
it is therefore a quintessential
expression of femaleness
porn did make me trans
it's funny Media Matters does all these
hit pieces on me because I've suggested
that this kind of pornography transes
people makes people trans but this
very prominent transgender figure who
just won the Pulitzer Prize for the
perspicacity of his prose this guy is
saying the exact same thing that I'm
suggesting he's saying it more
definitively than I am I just raised the
question he's saying yes porn did
make me trans at the center of
porn oh this is kind of gross
yeah okay the the rest of this sentence
is legitimately too obscene to read on
this show I don't recommend that you
read it anyway but it basically he says
at the center of this pornography is
this body part and he he reduces women
down once again simply to the act of
being violated
okay
people are going to attack him a lot of
people on the left are attacking him for
letting the secret out I think he
probably deserves the Pulitzer if if he
doesn't deserve the Pulitzer he's at
least more deserving of the Pulitzer
than other people who have won it or who
have been finalists in recent years I
think of that guy Tony easy codes who he
won the national book award and he was a
finalist for the Pulitzer that guy has
never said anything interesting in his
entire life all he does is just parrot
silly Normy liberal platitudes and tells
liberal white people what they want to
hear and he certainly does not deserve
any of these awards at least this guy is
upsetting the norm at least at least
this poor man suffering from
transgenderism who got totally addicted
to this weird kind of pornography and
he's got all these extremely perverse
ideas about what a woman is deeply
misogynistic ideas at least he's saying
something that one upsets the status quo
and makes people think but two I think
reveals
really troubling aspects of modern
leftism of where liberalism leads in
society and of what transgenderism
means what it does what it what it
reduces you to
I I I
may even read the guy's book
it's so wrong I mean this is the this is
the silver lining in the storm cloud of
transgenderism is
with a lot of liberal policies it's easy
to keep it out of sight out of mind it's
easy to to ignore and neglect the
absurdity of it all
so even even with something as serious
as abortion with abortion you just don't
see it right abortion is what happens in
that dark corner of town in that scary
looking building but you don't have to
see that you don't need to go over there
abortion it's an act of murder but it
occurs inside a woman's womb most of the
time and so you don't need to think we
can just ignore it it's okay but with
the transgender issue which people could
ignore for a long time because there
were three or four people probably on
Earth who actually Express themselves
this way now it seems to be everywhere
it's in your kid's school it's in your
workplace
it's on your daughter's sports team and
so you can't ignore it anymore and it's
so absurd this guy Andrew Chu is just so
obviously not a woman and the way he
describes women being effed is what a
woman is
being effed is what a female is he says
getting f'd makes you female that's so
obviously not true it's so hideous it's
so perverse it's so obviously the the
hysterical ranting of someone whose
brain has been melted by pornography
that that you begin to wonder okay what
else is wrong about this movement so I I
hand it to him great great stuff man
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles do
you remember the last time you got a
free phone you started out feeling great
and then came the Hefty activation fees
the four line requirements and of course
the binding contract Pure Talk is giving
you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy phone
without the feeling that you've been
duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT and T-Mobile
and here's the thing you will be on
America's Most Dependable 5G network not
just a similar one the same one how do I
know I'm a customer so make the switch
to Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company that I'm proud to stand behind
because they are proud to stand behind
our mission at the daily wire and they
offer a fabulous product they've got a
us-based customer service team which
frankly is more than enough reason I
think to make the switch to help you
make the switch in as little as 10
minutes go to puretalk.com Knowles for
your free Samsung Galaxy when you sign
up for unlimited talk text and unlimited
data puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans buy Americans the
greatest media moment of the last
six months two years I don't know
CNN's reaction to the CNN Town Hall
featuring Donald Trump his first big TV
appearance since he was president
I I don't
this might be the funniest clip I've
ever seen in my life
many of you have expressed deep anger
and disappointment many of you are upset
that someone who attempted to destroy
our democracy was invited to sit on the
stage in front of a crowd of Republican
voters to answer questions and
predictably continue to spew lie after
lie after lie and I get it it was
disturbing and it was certainly
disturbing to hear that audience young
and old our fellow citizens people who
love their kids and go to church laugh
and applaud his lies and his continued
defamation of a woman who according to a
jury of his peers he's sexually abused
and defamed
as good a job as Galen Collins did
trying to fact check him it is
impossible to fact check fully because
he lies so shamelessly you have every
right to be outraged today and angry
never watched this network again but do
you think staying in your Silo and only
listening to people you agree with is
going to make that person go away
we're sorry you can turn off CNN it was
terrible we had
the president
we had the president very popular
president come on he's going to run for
president again half the country likes
him
Anderson Cooper I guess is trying to
make this point in a way he's more
reasonable than most other people in The
Establishment media in that he's saying
look it's important to hear from the
leader of the political opposition we're
not such a totalitarian society yet that
we can all agree to just throw the
leader of the opposition completely in
the gulag I know that we Liberals are
trying to prosecute him I know we're
trying to throw him in prison
I know all the while we decry of
Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping for doing
exactly the same thing but we it's
different when we do it and I know that
we're but we're not there yet
okay we haven't reached the the degree
of political control that Putin and she
have in their respective countries and
so we've got to at least pretend like we
should maybe hear from the political
opposition what makes the clip so funny
is just the seriousness
many of you
or deeply troubled by what you saw last
night
it was the former president saying that
we need a better economy
last night we saw this madness evil man
the four
and he said that we used to have more
Law and Order and we should restore
Justice
can you imagine oh goodness
scares me it's going to keep me up at
night boy what a clip that was huh if
you want to get more of those if you
want long interviews with Michael and if
you want the yes or no game if you want
face off if you want sizzling daily
commentary you gotta subscribe click
that bell ring that thing on the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time